foreign
[Music]
there are many shall we say strange
things about male Tick-Tock star Dylan
Mulvaney who has amassed a million
dollar Fortune from endorsement deals
ever since deciding that he wants to
pretend that he's a woman perhaps the
weirdest aspect of Mulvaney's uh very
profitable
Woman face charade is his obsession with
tampons products that those of us with a
male and atomical structure have no use
for and Mulvaney has a male anatomical
structure because he is again a male no
matter how often or how obnoxiously he
claims the contrary yet much is revealed
here I think about the trans phenomenon
and all of it is extremely bizarre and
disturbing so backing up for a moment in
April
Mulvaney who's still in the early days
then of his uh days of girlhood stick
recounted an alleged incident that
sparked his resolve
to always carry tampons
listen
stage 12 of being a girl and I just
picked up some tampons and y'all are
probably thinking Dylan where are you
gonna put those they're not for me but
this last weekend I was in the restroom
and the girl in the stall next to me was
like hey do you have a tampon and I
froze I was like sorry no but in that
moment I decided you know what I'm
always gonna have one on hand for anyone
who needs it you come over to my house
and we're having a glass of wine I got a
tampon for you if we're in the club
together and then we go to the bathroom
I got a tampon for you women supporting
women love ya
now I confess that I have
um no personal first-hand knowledge of
what goes on inside a woman's bathroom
because I'm a man just like this guy the
only difference is that one of us
respects a woman's right to privacy and
the other one of us is Dylan Mulvaney
all that to say if I had to guess
I would suspect that a woman shouting to
a stranger in the next stall asking for
a tampon
is not a normal occurrence it reminds me
of the Seinfeld scene where Elaine asks
for her asks her stall neighbor for some
toilet paper something that I've never
personally heard or seen anyone do in
real life ever and if I were ever on the
receiving end of such a request in a
public bathroom I would consider it a
horrendous breach of public bathroom
etiquette
yeah perhaps these kinds of exchanges do
happen sometimes in the women's restroom
I don't know it's just interesting that
Dylan Mulvaney had quote been a girl for
like 12 days and had already encountered
that
but whether he made it up or not
the point is that he decided to always
carry tampons around for any woman who
might need it he expected that women his
fellow women as he considers them would
fall over themselves to thank and
congratulate him for volunteering to be
a tampon Repository
but instead actual women just found the
whole thing very creepy and gross
and Dylan felt offended by that he felt
offended that women were not more
appreciative of his acts of tampon
charity and that led to this video
posted this week
day 271 of being a girl or I'll say
woman for this one because this video is
for the women on Twitter who just really
don't like me hello ladies we got a lot
to cover but let's first talk tampons I
haven't talked about tampons on here
lately because I don't use them I'm a
woman who doesn't have a uterus I know
this and science was my strongest
subject in high school I was also
shockingly good at math but I digress I
just sometimes carry one in case anybody
needs it and that seems to have just set
the world on fire in some pretty nasty
ways
and this is a conversation that's been
going on for months I just haven't
chimed in because I'm so tired of
sticking up for myself over something
that was so pure intentioned but now
Twitter is just a blaze the bigger
problem at hand is that you feel me
carrying a tampon around is a threat to
you and your Womanhood
how is someone doing something nice so
repulsive to you
because listen to this if a man whether
he was your boyfriend or your husband
could even be your gay best friend kept
a tampon for you at his house just in
case he needed it you'd gush over him
you would run to brunch on Sunday and
tell all your gal Pals that he's so
thoughtful and he cares and he listens
and then a trans woman does it and all
of a sudden I'm the reason that there's
a tampon shortage you know it's it's not
because I'm misogynistic it's because
you're transphobic
you know we gotta work through this and
and babe caring for others it's the bare
minimum
yeah babe you know we all know that you
ladies are running to your Sunday brunch
and your fancy hats gushing to your gal
Pals about how your boyfriend walks
around in a fanny pack stuff with
tampons just in case you have a
menstrual emergency when he's around
using the internet without expressvpn
well it's like leaving your laptop open
and unattended at the coffee shop table
most of the time you're probably fine
but what if you turn around one day and
your laptop is gone it can easily happen
every time you connect to an unencrypted
Network Cafe in a hotel and an airport
hackers on the same network can access
your personal data it doesn't take a
genius to hack someone all you need is
cheap Hardware hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling
personal data on the dark web that's why
I use expressvpn expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so that hackers
can't steal your data we take a hacker
with a super computer over a billion
years to get past expressvpn's
encryption don't let that scare you
especially piano is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app click one
button plus it works on all devices so
you stay secure on the go no matter what
secure your online data today
expressvpn.com Matt walshow and get
three extra months free it's
expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show you
notice how Mulvaney's vision of
Womanhood is almost entirely derived
from Sex in the City episodes this is
one of the most glaring truths about
transgenderism the men who identify as
women are not only not women they also
understand women far less
than the average man who identifies as
what he actually is like this dude knows
a lot less about women than I do or like
any a normal man especially a married
man
so we're not women but we've been around
them we're married to one so we have
some sort of insight
this guy just doesn't understand women
at all
trans women know know vastly less about
women have a have a much you know
inferior understanding of Womanhood
so I may not have women totally figured
out but I do know that first of all most
of them aren't going to Sunday brunch in
the first place and if they do they
aren't talking about their boyfriends
and husbands attitudes towards tampons
in fact if I may be so presumptuous I'm
going to assume that almost every woman
on the planet would be deeply creeped
out if the men in their lives walked
around with extra tampons on hand all
the time
I can tell you that my wife has been to
brunch with the gal Pals which she would
never call them that by the way ever
um like maybe twice in the last decade
she's been to a Sunday brunch and if I
ever pulled a tampon out of my pocket
and asked her if she needed it she would
look at me with a mixture of confusion
and horror and she would assume that I
had gone completely insane
there would be no gushing to the gal
Pals about it
you know she might bring it up to a
female friend but it would be like in a
hushed and concerned sort of tone like
he had tampons in his pocket How
concerned should I be about this
and by the way also whatever happened to
listening to women right so we're
supposed to listen to him so
dylum of any thinks that women should be
appreciative of the tampon thing
he's admitting that the women are
telling him uh no thanks please don't
please stop doing this this is weird
just we don't need just stop by you
don't need to worry about the tampons
let us figure that out
and and rather than listening to the
women who are telling him what they want
he says well you should know you should
want something else
because the other thing you notice about
how Milton about this uh tampon Saga
with Dylan Mulvaney aside from the fact
that he's trying to become a woman and
yet has apparently never met one it's
also how condescending and patronizing
and threatening he is to the very people
he's trying to emulate
trans identifying men are very much
executing a hostile takeover of
Womanhood
and though he cloaks his condescension
and insults in a very thin veil of faux
kindness
it all still comes through loud and
clear especially at the end listen to
what he says at the end
P.S I am also very nervous for you just
because
hopefully soon transphobia won't be as
tolerated online but your tweets are
forever and I don't want those to come
back and haunt you
okay
bye
he's nervous for you
he's trying to look out for you ladies
he's just concerned that he
he might have to ruin your life over
wrong think he loves you he's your
friend he cares for you so much and he
really doesn't want to have to destroy
you for expressing Politically Incorrect
ideas he doesn't want to have to do it
it would hurt him more than it would
hurt you
he would hate it if your defense of
biological reality came back to haunt
you
man would he hate that
so shut your mouth
get in line
let him use your bathroom and locker
rooms all he wants
let him appropriate woman who turned
into some kind of bizarre sex in the
city parody Let Him degrade your
femininity let him run around acting out
his tampon fetish let him do all of this
in front of you as a direct mockery of
you and do not object
because those objections might come back
to haunt you
this is the trans invasion of Womanhood
in a nutshell bizarre fetishistic
degrading condescending
push through with veiled threats and not
so veiled threats
so he's the perfect mascot in many ways
not of Womanhood
but of its Invaders and appropriators
and for that reason he is once again
today canceled and I will do it for this
portion of shows move over to the
members block
let's see there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]